we weren't going out to Bruce Willis I
mean he was one of the top three biggest
stars in in the world I originally wrote
the part for Matt Dylan he wasn't so
short he didn't 100% get it in the
meantime Harvey could tell so he would
invite friends to come over for the
weekend and there's Bruce Willis I've
never met him before he is a huge fan of
reservoir docks and then he goes uh hey
uh Quinton AR ra your script wow I mean
that blew my mind and he goes um I want
to play Vincent I kind of have a John
Travolta setup for Vincent what if I
play Jewels I know he's black but he
could just be a hipster dude so I think
about it all night long and finally I
realized I can't do it and he goes it's
all okay let me take you off the hook I
get it I go Bruce but I think you should
be in this movie read the script one
more time with the idea of you playing
Butch and if you don't respond you don't
respond and he goes okay I'll do that
and then I called him the next day and
he said Quinton I'm in